suspensor ackerman for wired.com just
got off an mv-22 tiltrotor marine osprey
coming from the USS Wasp about 60 miles
off the southeast Atlantic coast here to
marine corps air station cherry point in
North Carolina that was part of the bold
alligator exercise this is a very big
operation and the reason why it's so
important is because the Marines and the
Navy haven't really worked together as
part of a team for a decade as the
Marine Corps been rather busy in Iraq
and Afghanistan now what they're testing
with a lot of aaron c assets from the
USS Wasp USS kearsarge USS san antonio
the USS Iwo Jima the French mr. all ship
and assets from other nations is how all
of them can work together as a team to
make sure that when they face threats
from nations like China and Iran they
can sort of knit together as a whole to
take territory away from hostile forces
the exercise in particular tested some
capabilities that the Navy in the Marine
Corps wanted to make sure they have like
for instance had a sail through a very
narrow strait like the choke point at
the Strait of Hormuz off the coast of
Iran we're about a fifth of the world's
oil transits every day that was
something they tested on Sunday today
the Marines in the navy tested how they
come ashore at off the Virginia coast
near a fork ticket and we're waiting to
hear a lot of what their lessons learned
were from that how they ended up working
together how they might need to refine
some techniques and tactics and
capabilities and procedures of the
future to figure out how they can work
together on this very important mission
you